in this minecraft world every block you
break gives you a random block
this is the dirt block but watch what
happens when i break it
not dirt so you would think a flower
would drop a flower it drops flower pots
and a little tree that's kind of ironic
and see that time we have one hour to
get as much material as possible and
then kill the ender dragon now here
here's the thing
yeah if when we fight the ender dragon
we don't kill it in under 10 minutes
we all have to eat a granola bar covered
in ketchup the most disgusting thing
ever that doesn't make sense those two
things don't go together and it confuses
me
well then go gather armor and stuff so
we can kill the ender dragon
all right unless you like granola bars
covered in ketchup what if one of us
secretly liked that and they're gonna
sabotage
so if you break this wood block you get
a flower and if you lay the flower and
break it
you get nothing okay the strat is to
break this wood because it's just giving
me different wood
oh wow you get polished and did slabs
from
sand guys
guys guys guys guys come to me right now
oh you got iron what gives you iron
these white flowers right here
[Music]
what what i got gold whoa whoa whoa who
took all this stuff i got iron helmet
bro
iron helmet oh wow chandler just swoops
in and does a share
wait gravel gives you no blocks don't
tell granny
i'm just gonna find flowers to pick yeah
honestly
oh i found more white flowers yeah you
boy got iron pickaxe
okay what if i were to tell you these
red flowers get you absolutely nothing
oh i got snowballs from dirt
guys cobblestone gives you iron what
okay this is
gg oh guys i got plenty of food
don't worry oh wait i found cobblestone
it's whatever this
stuff is oh i'm about to smelt us a ton
of iron carl doesn't have to eat ketchup
we're not eating ketchup today boys
chris brought his trap hard pants
i'm gonna need a little bit better of a
haul than that
carl our neighbors are gonna kill you
corn flour will this not give me my
what just happened what was that bro
this donkey won't die
dude i'm making so many tools for us we
gotta be stacked
oh i found a mushroom biome let's see
what lies within
dirt what the chandler what you doing
chicken
all right fair jimmy what are you doing
just wondering all right
i'm gonna be honest i don't remember
what anything turns into
i've literally just been picking flowers
the entire time give me some
iron armor so if you're wondering cows
drop black
whoa which bag's the question what do
sheep drop hello
chiller wait a minute girl hey guys in
case you're wondering sheep drop
fences that's kind of ironic because
that's the one thing that keeps them
locked in
sometimes we produce our own struggles
oh i found more white flowers ender pro
oh yes yo fun fact though you boy got 45
higher what are we doing
ender pearlin that's what we'd be doing
wait don't throw it i'm tired of walking
no
what let's save them to get to the end
all right well in case you're wondering
snow does not give you anything i
thought it would be epic wow thank god
you wasted an ender pearl
jimmy dude come on yo you man's full
iron armor look at this
hey carl yeah the blocks aren't the only
thing that's random you're so random
gosh and quirky guys i'm going mining to
see what i can get
i'm ready to answer the million dollar
question what do you get if you
baby villager i got diamonds well he's
running away
wow all right nothing how did you get
diamonds carl
it's the swamp vines no way dude it's a
diamond divine
all right get everyone diamond armor
carl so how about this
only the person who kills the ender
dragon doesn't have to eat the granola
ketchup bar what do you guys think about
that one i don't like it all right so
are we all in agreeance that
only the person who kills them should
not have to eat it all right that's fair
i'm also starting to think i shouldn't
share my diamonds then all right carl if
you just want to do your boys like that
that's fair
i just need food i'll i'll settle for
food at this point oh i found actual
diamond
i was playing as a team player and got
all that iron forever i'm bringing it
for everybody i'm gonna have three
full stacks of diamonds diamond ore
turns into magma block
oh my gosh cobweb gives you like hella
good stuff
oh my gosh we all founded these droopy
white flowers
i don't know but it's changing the game
for me i can't sprint anymore so i have
to walk around just looking for these
droopy flowers
i feel like a droopy flower right now
i'm gonna make a
diamond block and see what it gives me
diamond block on the ground i'm gonna
i'm gonna pickaxe it up
it didn't give me anything oh my god
that's stupid look
it just spits out diamonds who did this
what would we do without you carl carl
you're a genius for finding this
carl i don't understand why everyone
hates you editors keep that part in
please
boys get back together let's all meet on
carl okay yes
uh hey i'm here let's go check out the
nether because i have no idea what we'll
get there
all right let's do it who has obsidian i
have six i don't have any where do you
get
it from i don't remember what do you
mean you don't remember
i just got obsidian somehow i don't
remember where it came from right this
is how you get obsidian you take
cobblestone and lay it down
okay mine it then you get in stone do
that and then boop
boop oh oh no i want to see what happens
if you break it
i don't think anything oh ooh diamond
block
i think i did it right i don't know
though light it up how do we light a
flint and steel
jimmy how do we get flint and steel
everybody grab stuff and break it and
maybe it'll turn into a
flint and steel all right i'm gonna
watch a youtube video to figure out how
to do it without flynn's steel
[Music]
and then we need to put wood over it and
eventually it will light it on fire
so we're just gonna have to wait for
this to oh that would be a very
oh go to the nether go
we have 10 minutes until we have to
battle the ender dragon let's see what
the nether gives us oh my gosh it's all
so random
oh a book a book a book yes we need
enchantment books these are good
oh bro i got knock back two efficiency
four five protection four quick charge
two
yeah dude find these books you gotta
grind for these books
carl why would you do that was that
necessary it was carl wait what did i do
oh oh mushrooms give you bread
you stole my bread let's go i got i got
a gavel i can take it
you're going to use a gapple on me
what are you guys doing i see you guys
chasing each other we were just playing
tag you know having fun
all right so we got piercing three
sharpness three why didn't we just come
here there's so much good ore
power three yo what the f
jimmy said we could sabotage did you
kill him wait
i'm not eating the granola bar i'm sorry
chandler
we are on the same team you idiot wait
so chris
actually killed chandler why jimmy was
trying to kill me
carl i think i think that was a cheap
move i think we need to teach him a
lesson carl here's the thing
earlier he tried to get me to betray you
and i didn't do it i was messing with
you and carl but i know not to mess with
chandler because they'll just leave and
go get mcdonald's
don't let him wait why can't i hit him
because i got a shield
dummy let's eat a gaffer let's do this
carl
oh wait did you go with him did you
follow him oh he's just eating
apples i've only taken three damage i
still have all my gold hearts hey
chandler
we're cool right man leave me alone
that's right
run away and stay away all right i took
care of him boys
just wasted all my dang bread is what
you did hey truce
nope you better stay in the real world
and never come into nether
carl we're still friends unless you
don't want to be my friend any more than
i understand but i'm also sad
i'm friends with everybody i got all
these books cause i found my stuff
and i got all the iron made at anvil two
minutes until we get teleported two
minutes
come on oh my gosh i'm not ready at all
ah how do we get bows did we figure that
out
nope all right let's just wing it we're
all just gonna die
all right little doggo you're gonna help
me all the way to the end we're gonna do
this together okay
he shook his head at me he said yes all
right
ten way no no
don't do it three it's the server two
one stop whoever kills the ender dragon
doesn't have to eat a granola bar
start working on the uh tower things hey
guys guys guys i think we have to avenge
chandler
are you guys going after me right now i
will dang his life regens i forgot
that's what i'm trying to do but jimmy's
trying to kill me let's let chris
do that first jimmy he's gonna put he's
got a lava bucket out like i can't see
it
oh wow oh look at that oh hey i'm
perfect
all right maybe it wasn't the best idea
to not make arrows before we came to the
end
i'm working on it jimmy i'm working on
it
oh oh oh where is he where is he
oh he died take his stuff sorry about
that chris that's fine
i just was helping the entire group out
while jimmy was trying to kill me the
whole time
now that chris is gone we can actually
focus on taking out the ender dragon
here we go here we go you hurt my
feelings why
you teamed up against me with jimmy for
like three seconds and then i decided i
didn't want to pick that fight because
i'm not
as good as you
oh nope
all right well i died somehow oh we all
died
well carl it's all up to you or we all
have to eat this well you could have
just mlg probed it with your water
bucket do you think you could have done
that
do like dream would have done you always
talk about how you're better than dream
oh yeah
watch one of these all right jump up
wow dang i'm out of supplies to get up
where's your water bucket you idiot you
know what this means it's all carl's
fault
no ketchup covered granola bars let's go
boys stop eating them they're not
covered in ketchup i have four granola
bars here we're going to start off with
chandler's granola bar
oh here we go taylor okay
now we're going to do chris's he's had a
rough day we'll go easy on him
all right there we go we all got equal
ketchup on three
one two three oh
hey carl you doing okay